cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke rowski join us there get
your tickets by clicking the link in the
description below or by going to
timcast.net
next to next to a door with a sign that
says depress the uh the you know bar or
whatever for 30 seconds to open the door
this basically caused a stall in the
vote over the the the government
spending Bill he then says later you
know I thought pulling the fire alarm
opened the door which I'm sorry I don't
think he is so stupid he actually
believes that I think he's smart enough
to recognize if he says he intentionally
pulled the fire alarm he gets criminally
charged so it's uh I just thought it
opened the door but I got to tell you
ignorance of the law is no excuse for
breaking it he should be criminally
charged so after he gets a bunch of
flack from everybody saying you know
he's trying to stall in delay he then
has his Camp puts out a message saying
that they're all Nazis this is really
really funny let me see I I don't know
if they actually have the messages here
uh what he actually put out but uh he
then comes out here we go Tim cast.com
rep Jamal Bowman condemns use of Nazi in
memo issued to Democrats by his office
saying it is important to specify the
term Nazi to refer to members of the
Nazi party and neo-nazis and then here's
a tweet from John LaVine rep Jamal
Bowman says Michael nolles is a Nazi
hellbent on keeping only white men alive
and in power we cannot allow him and
others to push their evil agenda blah
blah blah so there you go we can sit
here and sing the Praises of Matt Gates
or uh uh Dr Ron Paul when he was in
office and this is what Democrats have
to offer I suppose for the record
Michael NS is a Christian uh Republican
not a Nazi he doesn't serve the Nazi
party and I'm prettyy sure his wife's
Jewish but all of that aside these
people are horrible nothing's going to
happen to Bowman he has Democrat
privilege you can do whatever you want
you can pull fire alarms you can be
racist you can right before we started
there was the ilhan Omar story about
giving illegals IDs it's like they can
do anything and they get more power
that's how they operate and they protect
their own much better than Republicans
do uh but this guy's a buffoon you guys
I'm sure you covered the video of him
screaming at Massie in the hallway a
couple months ago this guy is just he's
the worst of the worst but he's exactly
what the future of the Democrat Party is
he changed his story from uh I I thought
it would open the door when I pulled the
fire alarm to I was in a rush I had to
vote so I pulled the fire alarm he
changed his story very recently he's
saying that the door right the the door
is St the door is normally open he was
in a rush and when he got to the door
and saw that was closed he thought I
have to get to the capital building and
if I pull the fire alarm it'll open the
door so I can get through despite the
fact is a sign on the door explaining
how to open it is it now okay for
congressmen to pull fire alarms when
they're in a rush because that's the
precedent this will set if he doesn't
get arrested well I I I disagree the the
excuse he's making is I thought it
opened the door so it won't set
precedent but he should be arrested Ian
you should go to the capital right now
and go into that same building and that
same location and you and you should
test out your theory being I I just need
to leave here and then see what happens
to you because you could say you made it
made a quinky dink but that's actually a
really interesting point what if someone
goes in there and says the exact
Republican though no no I me just mean
literally anybody I mean you will get
arrested you pull the they're going to
arrest you and they're going to give you
all the insane BS you know disrupting an
official proceeding or whatever the
Democrats really don't like that one and
and how much government resources and
time are are you wasting MTG released a
very interesting video showing how what
uh this Congress member were saying was
an absolute lie but I think uh The
Babylon be definitely Takes the Cake
here as they H uh wrote an article that
was titled Democrats propose a 12
billion study to determine what strange
red handle thingy with fire alarm on it
does and they they really just nailed
this entire situation very well more
than any other news organization out
there as of course there's so many lies
by the Democrats there's Lies by the
Republicans too but all of them are just
full of crap he should be held
responsible for what he did doesn't this
just seem to you like this is the next
step of where the Democrats are
obviously going pulling fire alarms like
you've got John fedman in his hoodie and
they change the rules so he can wear
shorts and a hoodie but they changed it
back didn't they did they change it back
they did I I was away for a couple days
I might have missed one so they they
actually Chang it back yeah people were
pissed off about that one well that I
I'm I'm I have not heard that I
completely Amazed by that but he will
figure out a way around it but the just
the basic idea that every Norm that we
have everybody that is that is uh
respectful and decent and competent will
eventually be purged and you will just
get a bunch of people that pull fire
alarms and tell you that they don't know
what they're doing and a lot of people
will be like oh I guess he didn't know
what he was doing you know you know what
it is is uh all that is required of evil
to Triumph is that good men do nothing
and too many people allow people like
Bowman to to to run and win too many
people support it but what if someone
like pulled out a gun while they were
shooting a movie and they were like oops
and the gun went off and and they they
killed the cinematographer like like
Alec Baldwin did you would think like
ignorance of not knowing that the gun
was loaded with the bullet you would
think that's not an excuse to commit the
crime it's kind of a joke because should
be criminally charged the problem is our
system is broken and corrupt I I I don't
this is one I'm I'm going to have a hard
time letting go of this one because for
years to come people can pull fire
alarms Congress if this isn't taken care
of right away I hate to tell you they're
letting them go you got I mean you know
you know he'll probably get a ticket
they'll be like he got he got a fine his
office paid for it which is your tax
dollar something like that will happen
and then we'll be told it's because
America is systemically racist oh yeah
that's the next thing he's going to come
out say yeah of course he is they
wouldn't have done this to a black guy
Lauren bobert would have been walking
off scottf free yep white supremacy how
blackpilled are you um I'm a little
blackpilled about the nation as a whole
but I'm very white pilled on what's
going on here in Florida and I think
that that's the freedom or that's the
future of America we're going to kind of
go our different directions and it and I
and it's okay Florida declares
independence I I think we're probably
not that far from that to some extent in
some way I only mean that's part well
it's not even that you'd have to do that
this the states are set up to be
Laboratories of democracy and yes you
can't solve all the problems in your own
State because yes they can still screw
you they can still screw you at the
border by letting in all these people
but you can control your border to some
degree you control declare independence
no not today no not yet yes yesterday
please declare independence immediately
get away from the union and just leave
us alone please let's put it this way I
never thought I would have been a
separatist in the Star Wars prequels but
the more you watch them and you see
what's going on you kind of go well
actually when an entire system is
corrupt getting out of the system does
make sense I'm not for that well you
know the other problem with that is that
the red States if the red States really
were just like let's kind of all get
together and not not leave in like some
drastic way but just kind of do our own
thing have economic trading policies and
all that on our own the blue States will
never let them go Florida and Texas and
South Dakota don't want anything from
the blue States but you California wants
the money and the resources of Florida
they can't keep running these giant
deficits and all of this other
without Florida and the red States
because what's going to increasingly
happen we know this is happening all of
the functional people who build things
who want the government out of the way
who want to produce they're all moving
to the red States and they're leaving
the blue States and don't forget that
Lee zeldon who nobody knew about two
weeks before the New York gubinatorial
election he lost by about 500,000 votes
you know how many people moved out of
New York during Co about 400,000 so it
was that close to flipping what is like
the red uh The Bluest of blue States and
now it just got further so but this is
this is one of the the big components of
what happens in Florida and Texas why it
flips so red it's people coming here and
then voting red they're voting the right
way I mean I meet these people all the
time because people know that that I did
it very publicly but everyone I meet
here the amount of former Dems that now
tell me they firsttime Republicans do
you know the numbers on that the the
when Dan santis came into office someone
could check this the uh it I think the
Republicans were actually down by voter
registration and now they're up by like
400,000 or something like that someone
can give me the the real numbers on on
uh on our way here in the airport met
some fans and uh they're like oh cool we
love your show and I was like what do
you guys what are you up to and they're
like we're moving to Florida no joke
yeah they were like we're moving and I
was like wow I was like we're on our way
to Miami yeah Miami went red Miami
wented it's a major urban area urban
area is predominantly overwhelmingly
Democrat can I tell you something so
great about this is just how like
functional these people are I was doing
the show one day and I was talking about
the crazy oh it was right after I was in
San Francisco and I did this video that
went viral just the zombie apocalypse
right so I was talking about San
Francisco and la and Portland Seattle
all that and I said I don't know how
many homeless people there are in Miami
but I know it's not that many cuz you
never see them and we we take care of
business here literally while I'm doing
it my I get a text from Suarez the mayor
of Miami and he says Dave tell your
audience we have 348 and I'm working on
it like think about the functional
difference of the people that are
running this state and the City versus
almost the entire country I think you
were looking for numbers earlier uh
Republican party of Florida numbers for
that and 2023 was 50 5.2 million before
that it was 5.3 million in 22 so they
down 880,000 or something in 2020 it was
5.2 in 2023 it was 5.24 in 2020 I'm
going backwards let me go forward in
2019 there were 4.7 2020 there were 5.2
says 500,000 people joined the
Republican party in that year uh
2021 it went down from 5.2 to 5.1 so a
million registered Republicans left the
party 100,000 no no no oh yeah 100,000
I'm sorry I'm getting these numbers
wrong um it's this is from do.my
florida.com does that sound familiar
these the net number you're talking
about is basically in four years it's
about 500,000 more Republicans here and
that that is like a massively huge
number for a state that is now really
the reddest state in the nation I mean
the guy won by 20 points has a super
majority on 300,000 less Democrats in
2017 there was 4.5 million registered
Republicans today there are 5.2 million
uh registered Republicans in the State
of Florida how many Democrats there are
4.6 as of today and and in 2017 it was
4.8 this is a major urban urban State
like the the all of Florida is a
developed well we we personally have to
thank the Cubans here they've been
through socialism and and the communism
they're they're pretty based they don't
like centr centralization and I get
along with them very well cuz I come
from communist Poland we don't like
government there either they don't like
big government here as well but you know
the other thing that happens once you
start doing things right I think one of
the things the santis has done done
really well so for example I disagree
with to santis on the six we heartbeat
Bill personally my personal belief is 15
weeks that's kind of where I would even
be on 12 weeks but I'm I'm not as let's
say conservative on that but when you do
strong conservative policies not only do
you get strong conservative people to
move into your state you also scare off
the wack job lefties so somebody that
might have moved to Florida before
because of low taxes suddenly they're
like but wait a minute I like six-month
abortions I'm never going to move there
so it it actually doubly helps you you
get the good people coming and you're
also putting a force field so the
wackadoodles don't don't move in but
there's a a major negative to that and
if you look at what California did with
illegal immigration they end up getting
between one about one or two extra seats
in Congress to vote against your rights
ban your right to keep in be arms and
things like that by breaking the law by
what by allowing them to vote you mean
they don't allow them to vote whatever
it is they allow them to do when
non-citizens are allowed into the state
of California they are counted in the
census which then abortions
congressional seats so you don't need to
be a citizen in order for your presence
to have an effect on the Electoral
College and Congress I blame this on the
federal government and and also the
Banana Republic of California there's
actually is a a risk here if all of the
people are leaving their areas and I'm
not saying they should stay they should
certainly be moving away from these
cities in my opinion for the most part
but if they all come to Florida and then
Florida wins by 20 points if you're
thinking about strategic allotment of
your resources Jerry mandering comes to
mind you want to make sure that you're
putting just enough people in the right
places to win those districts if you get
half a million people from three or four
states put them all in Florida you're
well Florida's already red you know
Florida doesn't need 500,000 new people
Florida did get more seats because of
that oh for sure for sure that's one
extra seat just about one more seat is
going to be given to Florida but you'd
be better off winning outright win or
take all states by putting a 100,000 in
five states as opposed to 500,000 in one
state to be clear as a new flan I'm not
for everybody movie here like you know
what I mean like you really do need to
spread it out and as a nation we do have
to if we're going to remain United at
all which gets us back to the other
thing but yeah we need to so convinced
but look a whole no if we are too I
think maybe we aren't but yeah I think
yes well look how many people moved to
Tennessee in the last three years I mean
it's it's a crazy amount of people as
well but you know it might just be we
talk a lot about National divorce Civil
War what it means and there are a lot of
people that think this is like where we
are now is where we will be until the
fighting Starts Now there's there's
another reality San Francisco is
disarray it's falling apart Los Angeles
is falling apart there's there's feces
everywhere there they the Westfield mall
they they was it um they relinquished
the claim to the property to their
lender oh in San Francisco yeah yeah
yeah the mall uh two of the biggest
hotels did this the reality may be that
these blue States stay on this path we
maintain stability for five six seven
years and these cities just lose all
their political power and capital then
right now they can claim oh we make all
the money and blue states do all the
work you're a city okay it's outside of
the cities is all red for the most part
if these cities are mismanaged to this
degree and their policies are going
insane and people are leaving it's
called The Brain Drain the people who
are leaving are the hard workers who
don't want to be in a place where
they're being oppressed for their hard
work so they go to Florida where they
can strive where they can they can uh
Thrive and then the people who remain
are demanding of the government the
government raises taxes the system falls
apart give it 5 10 years New York will
be a a a pigy pit stain no one's going
to want to be there anymore and they
will have no political capital and then
people are going to look to Florida and
they're going to look to Texas and
they're going to look to Tennessee well
the next version is then between the
fenel and God knows what sex these
people are doing and everything else
then the super virus starts the zombie
apocalypse and then and then yes we do
have to put Gators at the border to keep
these freaks
out do you think you could have
benefited at all California if you'd
stayed no I did everything I could do I
fought as hard as anyone I campaigned
with Larry Elder I got audited by the
state three days after the campaign
ended that was the day I put my house
for sale for real um California wants to
go in that direction there are good
people there I was just there I had
dinner with some friends like there are
still a good people remaining but
everyone's depressed it's all they talk
about uh yes you're going to find
pockets of Sanity of course it's not all
that crazy everywhere but you're right
the brain drain it's not just what it
does to uh the businesses and everything
else it's what it does to the human
Spirit when you realize you're in a you
why would you ever open a store a
freaking sneaker store or a pizza joint
if you know on any given moment they're
going to burn it down what it does to
your family so what happens is the brain
drain is the people who normally start
the businesses leave cuz they can't and
the people who don't start businesses
stay and demand of the
government this is the same exact thing
that happened in in Cuba Cuba faced a
major brain drain and this is why a lot
of people speculate that we had a total
almost collapse of their society because
everyone was leaving Cuba leaving
communism leaving somewhere where the
government was oppressing them taxing
them controlling them and they left for
places like like Florida and and this is
why Cuba is the state that it is now
this is why the Soviet Union fell this
is why communism never works and the
people in that country usually go hungry
because the people capable are the ones
usually punished by that entire system
you want you want to go while you're in
Miami to a place where everyone's going
to know you and buy you a Mojito go to
Little Havana down here and hang out
with some of the Cubans who will talk
about Freedom until 4 in the morning
hopped up on sugar and rum these are
good people who care they care about
freedom
you said moito yeah no mint for me you
mentioned ciche we'll have a we'll we
don't drink no booze here we'll have a
little Kucha with them but
but little cucha yeah yeah yeah but but
no the Cubans here are are very based
and they're they're very very very
strongly independent they don't like
government they don't like
centralization and I think this is why
Florida is so great because of them I I
keep thinking about pills you mentioned
earlier like the brain drain and it's
all kind of circling around my head now
like just distractions in general
playing video games watching porn taking
opiates or whatever opioids what do you
what is your vision for how to help
people I mean actually I I I'll just say
uh weed apparently can help people with
withdrawals you know it can help
suppress some of the pain that felt by
opiate withdrawals CBD CBD so but there
there are paths to maybe introduce new
new new things but like what do you see
cuz I think this is like no matter how
political you get always comes down to
if the population's doped up population
ain't going anywhere well look I'm not
Jordan Peterson so I'm not in the
business of giving life advice to people
but you know I do my August Off the Grid
thing for one month a year for seven
years I freaking put this thing in a
safe and I have no news no TV no social
media nothing I know absolutely nothing
couple years we've gone to Bora Bora a
couple years this year we were in the
Mexican rainforest wow and just
disappear this year actually this year I
really now having kids this year I
didn't want to do I didn't read any
books I just did nothing I I I mean we
exercised ate good food but that was it
and then I come back and I have fresh
eyes on this you know Tim since me and
you were we're like OG in this freaking
thing right like like think about it
where we started and and where both of
us are respectivly we've been doing this
for a long time I was later than a lot
of people it's yeah but roughly like
we're Old-Timers now in this game I hate
to tell you man but when when I first
met you you had freaking nothing and
you've built something amazing like
we've been in this for a long time and
how many people do you know that we're
in the similar world as us that have
lost their freaking mind gone crazy just
every the whole thing breaks them the
politics breaks them the money breaks
them the Fame breaks them or or a lack
of money or lack of Fame blah blah blah
and and to me one month so I take one
12th of the year without this freaking
thing and I come back and I'm fresh and
I'm ready to go and and I think it's
kept you know kept me in the game you're
asking people to basically uh you we
we'll do a Marvel reference so that
everybody everybody can can understand
and enjoy yeah in in Infinity War when
Thor is standing in the way of the of
the the star uh the star Forge you're
asking people in this in politics to St
stand in the center of a forge being
burned on all sides not everybody can
handle that oh that's where he gets the
big hammer or something right he gets he
has to and it blasts him and he's like
and he's like dying yeah this is all
right I'm asking people to do that is
that such a big deal this this job is
being inside of a pre pressure cooker
yeah 24/7
Non-Stop and some people like popcorn
yeah when's the last time you did one
day one day uh no usually uh I would say
like Saturdays yeah so you do try to I
would say Saturdays I'm like 99% reduced
all right you know like I I still check
my phone for text and stuff like that
but uh usually Saturday morning on and
then around Sunday night I'm back on and
I'm picking everything Twitter hell hole
yesterday man there's nothing like it oh
it'll get you it'll it'll bring you to
hell and then you're just lucky if you
can get back in but I'll tell you you do
this if you can try to do it even for a
weekend or a week or whatever like when
I'm 3 weeks into this thing I'm
remembering friends that I have not
thought of second graders I can
basically remember every kid in my class
I'll have whole songs albums in my brain
I can tell you every word like there is
so so much stuff in the recesses of the
human mind that we just we just
completely uh on with day-to-day
holy this person who I don't know I
never heard of they said something and
I'm going to destroy them for it and
we're doing that all day long and there
is there is Magic in us in our in our
minds your dopamine receptors your
dopamine receptors are just being
blasted and it's pretty much just just
un unhooking from The Matrix I used to
do it every every two weeks but things
have been so crazy it's been it's been
difficult within the last few years to
take a break but you reminded me I need
to take a break that's it's just like
meditation if you can't meditate for 10
minutes you got to meditate for 20
minutes exactly exactly the machine
ain't going to slow down I hate to tell
you this is why vacation is important
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net
for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time